welcome to this special edition of
hannity
standing up for american values i'm
judge janine pirro and tonight for sean
democrats continue to spin in a million
different directions
as their destructive agenda continues to
fail in every corner of the country
and it's getting so bad and so
disconnected from the american people
that they're trying to rewrite history
for example just look at liberal darling
stacey abrams
who is now trying to claim she was never
opposed to voter id and says she is
actually backing democratic senator joe
manchin's voting reform
efforts but stacy we have the tape
compare what she's saying now to what
she said just
months ago take a look just give me a
list
of the provisions that you objected
it shortens the federal runoff period
from nine weeks to four weeks
okay it restricts the time a voter can
request and return an absentee ballot
application
right it requires that a voter have a
photo identification
or some other form of identification
that they're willing to surrender
in order to participate in absentee
ballot
process that's one of the fallacies of
republican talking points that have been
deeply disturbing
no one has ever objected to having to
prove who you are
to vote it's been part of our nation's
history since the inception of voting
and it gets even worse for abrams as one
new york times writer is pointing out
her new position is eerily similar
to the georgia voting law that she
adamantly opposed
and called jim crow 2.0 and that
biden called jim eagle remember this
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
i mean this is gigantic
so joe and stacy what changed
could this dramatic turnaround be taking
place because
abrams and the rest of her far left
socialist cabal
see the writing on the wall and know
that americans of
all races and all walks of life
overwhelmingly support voter id
because get this now even democratic
senator
george democratic senator from georgia
rafael warnock is falsely claiming that
he never opposed voter id
so yet again democrats are not telling
the truth
lying over and over again and destroying
whatever
credibility they had left all along the
way
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else